et le césar du meilleur acteur est
attribué à pierre niney dans yves saint
laurent dans les duels de saint-laurent
et qui ont donc de gaspard ulliel il
avait déjà été nommé en 2012 ta meilleur
espoir quand j'ai regardé les filles en
2013 dans cette catégorie aussi aux
comme des frères d'hugo geslin il a
écouté regardé l'interview du couturier
afin de se familiariser avec sa voix
jusqu'à l'adopter et il a même appris à
dessiner comme lui avec le concours
d'autres c'est nazi qui a travaillé avec
le créateur
on le retrouvera les 18 mars dans un
homme idéal aux côtés d'annie girardot
il
merci merci beaucoup
j'ai l'impression de la sensation d'être
en caméra subjective là est d'arriver
dans une eau de vie je vois juliette
binoche et kirsten stewart me tend un
césar c'était très étrange
waouh merci merci aux votants à tous
ceux qui ont voté pour moi
du fond du coeur merci à jalil lespert
qui est là merci jalil de ta confiance
est évidemment de ta sensibilité avec
laquelle tu nous a filmés guillaume
charlotte des mois merci de ton
intégrité ta fidélité et puis je vais
remercier wassim bgi snd et puis
évidemment guillaume gallienne guillaume
qui est l'autre moitié de ce film
l'autre moitié de ce couple de cette
histoire de création cette histoire
d'amour
guillaume et baky fatalement du cou et
l'autre moitié de ce césar mais comme
nous tendait déjà eu cinq je vais le
garder suis là par contre l'année
dernière si ça te si ça te va comme ça
je voudrais remercier tous les
techniciens du film qui ont travaillé
avec une ambition dingue l'ambition du
film que j'ai à lille avait en tête
depuis le départ
alors merci merci aux techniciens et
puis merci à ma famille mes parents et
mes t aimais 2 et mes deux soeurs
excusez moi et mes deux soeurs pour ce
qu'ils m'ont donné plus précieux
l'éducation est l'amour merci à natasha
romanoff il révèle un atout sérieux et
non sérieux et puis merci à mes proches
puis je voudrais dire un mot pour les
nommer qui ont été nommés avec moi est
remontée ce micro qui infernalement
beaucoup trop bas décidément je voudrais
un mot pour les nommer les six nommés
avec moi je veux vous dire que j'ai pour
beaucoup d'entre vous je rêve en voyant
vos films depuis que je subtil depuis
toujours
que ce soit au cinéma en tant qu'acteur
ou que réalisateur au théâtre ou dans
des caméras cachées peu importe peu
importe
merci et puis je vais avoir un mot
évidemment pour gaspard avec qui on a eu
une année un peu spéciale tous les deux
et je je voudrais te dire que je crois
que le respect ton respect et notre
amour commun de ce métier je le sais et
de notre modèle yves saint laurent c'est
parti ce génie a été la meilleure
réponse je crois à tous ceux qui ont
voulu commenter simplifiée opposé mettre
en compétition à tout prix je crois que
c'était la meilleure réponse c'est de se
concentrer sur notre art ensuite j'aurai
juste une
un remerciement adressé à tous les
votants qui ont cette année ouvert une
porte au jeune réalisateur aux jeunes
acteurs merci du fond du coeur
ne pensez pas que c'est anodin ça nous
touche en tout cas je vais parler pour
moi ça me touche je le dis comme une
bienveillance profonde et cette
bienveillance
je me rends compte qu'elle est tellement
importante pour jouer le regard
bienveillant des gens alors merci pour
cette bienveillance
je crois que aujourd'hui moi j'ai grandi
j'ai eu la chance de grandir avec cette
bienveillance elle m'a permis de rêver
d'avoir des rêves depuis que multi et ce
soir d'être devant vous
cette bienveillance elle est nécessaire
parce que on a besoin je crois
aujourd'hui au delà des acteurs et au
delà des artistes aujourd'hui en france
d'une jeunesse qui rêve et qu'on leur en
donne les moyens
alors merci encore une fois
merci de ce césar merci de se souvenir
et merci aux bienveillant